hey friends welcome to the first project
today we're diving into a data set
that i picked from data camp i don't
know if you heard of this
website but it's like mainly a website
where you can learn how to code and
especially for data science in the field
of data science it's a very useful
platform
so an app i'm actually a premium member
of data camp
and
i will be developing a project which is
one of the the the projects in this in
this platform
and all the data sets of course i also
are grabbing them from from datacam
itself
and in the project there is the the the
data sets uh set i mean the the group of
data sets that we're going to work with
which are basically four data sets
and which later we'll be uh take a look
look at them and then also the questions
that confirm the project i also got them
from from datacam
and actually
you can also
see the solutions and are also in that
account so that was really cool because
i could compare my
solution my my solutions and my answers
with the answers
of the
what's in data camps so i can be sure
that
the solution and the answers are correct
because i could compare it now the level
that you're going to need to follow up
uh the project and be able to
um handle it and and maybe reach a
solution
it's a basic understanding of the
pandas model
of python
and if you
think you don't have
yet this basic understanding of pandas
a very good resource
and
and that is also free that you can watch
and practice to reach this
level
it's the the playlist of code basics
which i actually
watch and it's really really really good
and i would suggest you to watch the
first
nine videos and with that you will be
able to you will have the
this basic understanding of pandas to be
able to solve this project
and then
so the other thing that you are going to
need
is to have a basic understanding as well
of the matplotlib and model of python
and also i would suggest you to if you
don't have this if you think you don't
have this level yet
and i would suggest you to watch and the
code basics playlist of matlib which are
seven videos and i also watch this and
watch this playlist and it's really
really good explained
and with that and you will have the
basic understanding of matlow leap to
follow up
this project and basically the group of
data sets there there are only i mean
there are four data sets
and all these data sets you can you will
be able to find them in my github
profile
and so you don't have to
do anything weird or
so it's going to be like really easy
like all the resources are
just in this link
and that's going to be it
and then the other thing you will also
need to
develop and attempt this this project
is you will have to uh probably download
the anaconda distributor of python
and which is going to basically set you
up all the data science models of python
in your computer and so you don't have
to bother
um
searching for all the
different packages and different models
and downloading it by yourself because
once you download the anaconda
distributor everything will be set you
up
for you so you can and
you will have all the packages available
and it's just really really easy
and i i will also show it when i share
my screen how you can do it but it's
extremely extremely easy shouldn't take
you more than five minutes
and then with the anaconda distributor
you will have the jupiter notebook which
is where we are going to
write all our code and show all the
analytics and all that and that
is also one of the things that comes
with the anaconda distributor so um if
you just download the
anaconda distributor you will have
everything all the packages and the
jupyter notebook which we will be using
all right guys let's start with this
little project here
and
let's see okay
and
so
basically all you need
to start this project with me
it's
this link
okay because um this is my profile in
github
and here you will be able to find all
the files that i'm going to be using in
this project
and
don't
don't this this this file doesn't matter
but
and the other files like
the these four files are
we are going to be using them for the
project
and also
so the other thing that you're going to
need for this project
it's um the anaconda distributor
which is a
it's a distributor in python which
basically is going to set you up all the
the data science models that you are
going to need
for following in this project and the
next project that i'm going to be doing
as well and so it's very easy you just
have to download it here
and then this is going to
take you like once it's downloaded to
these kind of and what this page is well
this application
and you just have to launch
to in this jupyter notebook you launch
it
which then it's going to open you like a
terminal here
which is in fact
going to open this um
this notebook which is
um hosting
through the web
all right
and so so
um okay so i think we have everything we
need
and
okay so i have here my jupiter notebook
i'm just going to be creating
a new notebook just have to go to new
then python3
okay so here
we are ready
to start coding and start um
doing the project
so let's first check on the questions
let me see what are the questions
here there are questions okay
so
first question
well i'm just gonna take it guys i'm
just gonna
put it like this you know because
and so we have everything in one
place oh i hate this about jupiter
notebook that's
sometimes is difficult with the space so
one recommendation is just make a lot of
space when you're going to put something
but okay
all right guys let's start
so first question
print the highest weekly sales
for each department
in the walmart data frame
leaving your assets to the top five in
the sending order okay
and
first of all
i would suggest that we should explore
this data frame
and walmart data frame
and so we will take it from the github
my github profile
and and
before i'm just gonna be importing some
pandas
as pd
import numpy
s and p
and we are yeah we are going to be using
math.live as well
so import math plot leave
the pi plot
pi plot is kind of like the the inter
the sub model which is like an interface
of math.lib
and this is where we're going to be
creating all of our figures and axis and
all that to visualize our data which has
been asked here
as plt all these are the alias that we
are calling for each of our
python models
and so i'm just going to execute this
and go to the next cell
i'm just going to create a bunch of
cells here
all right
i actually want to take this and put it
here okay so
the first thing we are going to do
first thing we are going to do its um
okay go here
oh
okay was this really the first question
huh that's weird i thought it was
another one oh it's the second one yeah
so
you guys uh
this question i mean all of them are
kind of uh they're like not very
complicated but the way we have to
import this data
the for the avocado data frame
it's a bit it's a little bit weird
because it's a pkl
m file which is i think it's not that
common or at least not as common as a
csv
or i don't know any other kind of
formats really and
so we will see how to how to do
this but the command is is really really
really um easy with with pandas
but i didn't figure it out like i think
after
half an hour or something like that
okay so
what i'm going to be doing is um i'm
just gonna open
uh
i believe the data frame for walmart is
this
is this sales subset if i'm
if i'm correct let me just check guys
here
okay
so the
data frame for walmart is the sales
subset sorry that the name is not very
obvious for
what is being asked here but this is the
other frame that it has to be used
um
and okay so what i'm gonna do is i'm
just gonna open this file
and what i'm gonna do is just press here
in raw we don't have to download after
absolutely anything
and we just have to get this um this uh
link
this direction and we're just gonna do
a data frame for
walmart
equals pd
so we're calling the pandas model and
then we go
for the method for reading as a csv
simple csv
and
we're going to be pasting this
and
that's going to be pretty much it
now we i just execute this cell
and if we go and check the data frame of
walmart
and check the first
10 rows
and we see that we have the the data
frame is it is a little bit ugly guys
i
really don't like this unnamed equal
zero thing
actually i now remember that when i
solved
this this this project and i dropped
this column because i just hate it too
much to see it here
but
[Music]
it's not a problem really to to have it
so have it here so we can just leave it
here
or actually you know what i'm just going
to delete it because i really really
don't like it
i just deleted this data frame
walmart
this is like and when i imported the the
csv file
it's like it already had indexes you
know so
i believe it's uh
it just took
this as if it was like a column when
it's not like a real column it's just
like the indexes which
now is created again here and that's why
we see the again the zero one two three
four so that's why like this is not
really
serving any purpose this column so i
just really wanna drop this so we're
gonna do
the walmart
dot drop
drop
[Music]
and we are going to say columns equal to
whatever this is
which is
uh like this and see what happens now
let me see the
head of this thing
oh it's already done but
okay so we see that we have the same
data frame as before it
hasn't dropped
the columns the the
the column
that i wanted to drop
the solution for this is just to do it
this way like
so it is actually stored
in the data frame although now i'm
messing it up a little bit it shouldn't
be here i know what i'm doing
it should be here
and we run this and now we can run this
and we will see that now it has actually
executed this method or method for
dropping the
a specific column if i wanted to
drop or eliminate more columns
i had to just pass a list
and put all the labels all the strings
that are the names of the columns and
that would work okay but i just wanted
to drop that column and that's it okay
so
we have
the weekly sales
in here
these are the weekly sales okay
and says
for each department
so
i'm guessing that i
i'm i'm just wondering now like
how many uh departments do we have
and by the way this these data sets
there there's no um
i believe there there's no uh like nah
like missing values or anything like
that but
we can take a look by doing
the walmart
i'm going for
description or i just
want to see information about this data
set so
this is actually going to give us um
some information about like the
the name of the columns the
and something i really like to see here
it's um
the counts of non-null values okay
and we see that
all
all the values
for
each column
are all known nodes because
we have 10
774
um records and
is the same number for each and one of
these and
this is like the number of non-nulls so
we have
we don't have the missing values in this
data frame
so that's uh that's good news
and i believe there wasn't
not any missing value in any of the data
frames so we are not going to have any
problems with that but
i think it's a good practice to to check
always if if we are having like missing
values and stuff like that because
that can really
screw
our later analysis about
about what is being asked
so i proposed to solve this
is that we group
this by
for each
department then we um take the
maximum
we take the maximum for for for of the
weekly sales for each department and
then we
we order it order them you a like kind
of like a descending order so we will
see the top five
of the
of the weekly sales
for for the
different departments
all right so
first i'm just curious i i want to like
just
want to like
um
see the kind of like all the unique
values of this department column
just to see like how many groupings we
would be doing
and
for our later analysis
and so what i'll do is df walmart dots
department
and that's how we're going to select out
of all this
like out of the data frame we are
selecting only this
column okay so
we select the column and
we say
unique
and this should give us an array with a
unique value so we see we have a lot of
the different
departments
okay so our grouping is going to be
somewhat big okay
but there's no problem i just was
curious about how
how many like different departments
there are in this data frame
now we can proceed to do the analysis
and we're gonna do it's um because
this now i don't want to go up always to
see the data frame i want to have my
data frame here
so i'm going to print again
i don't know maybe five
records
okay and so
i'm gonna do
this right now we are going to be
grouping it df walmart
dots
and we are going to be taking the
department
group by
department
group by department and now there are
actually
two ways to
to to do the aggregation like right now
okay so right now if i return this
this is a data frame group die okay so
this is um
it's create it it's creating kind of
like a
like a group for each of these and for
for each unique value of this column and
it's gonna take all of the records that
have uh same department okay
so of course now to have a result and to
convert this into an actual
and data frame final data frame
what we what we do of course we have to
aggregate this and so there are two ways
to do this
and i think the easiest way is to just
um
take take it like this the
we we are going to put here like the
column name
of the column that we want to aggregate
which is the weekly sales
click
sales
okay
and here's like the method that we're
going to be using which is the maximum
because we want to get the maximum
values
out of the all the weeklies different
weekly sales for each department okay
so if we see what happens with this
this is what we get
these are the maximum values but
actually
i've just i like
i really
don't like too much this way of doing it
i prefer and i don't really know
why but
i just really like doing it this way
which is aggregating it by passing on a
dictionary and in the dictionary um
first we're going to type
the key
and of course the key and is the key is
going to be equal to the
to the column label to the name of the
column okay
which is going to be of course the
weekly
and we're going to specify here the
method
the aggregation and
aggregation method that we are using
for for for for for for aggregating this
and
each of these um
groups okay which as we know is the
maximum and what i like about these guys
is that
here we also have like the name
of the
of the column here
you see that right now there's no name
here but if we do it this way
it's going to be the same but at the
same time we will have this weekly sales
established in here
okay um so we will have it like this way
which i like it a little bit more okay
we see that department is like an index
and the only column that we have here is
the weekly sales if we want to turn off
the
the index or we want to just
make department another column
we can definitely do that
with an
argument that we can introduce here but
i don't have a problem really for having
the department as an index so i'm just
going to leave it like that
and
something else we want to do
in order to get the top five
it's we want to sort
these values
okay
and
sort the values by the weekly sales
and
we establish an ascending equal false
and this means that we are having a
descending order okay
and so because it's going to be
descending we the top five the first
five records that's gonna be our top
five you know
and we will have our results so we see
we are having
this is the top five that we are having
yes
and let's see if there was something
else bring the highest weekly sales for
each department
and limit your your results to the top
five percent so
yeah
and if we just want to limit the results
for the top five what we can do is just
call the head five
and then we got it guys
now let's go ahead and try to solve the
next task
which is what was the total
of
this i guess it's like uh
the name of a column of organic avocados
in
2017 in the avocado data frame okay i'm
just going to take this question
i just going to paste it here
this is the question two
and let's see what happens
okay so let's go ahead and
get this data frame okay
i'm gonna go
out from here
and in this case
our file as i was saying it's in this
pickle
extension
so it's not gonna be as straightforward
but it's gonna be
pretty straightforward just not as much
as
this kind of files guys
and okay so let's just go ahead and
okay yeah because we cannot i believe we
cannot see the raw
in the
github page you know so that's why it's
not as straightforward but
um what's gonna happen is that this is
going to download it you can also
download it here
and i'm just going to
um
take this where is it
[Music]
i'm just going to this folder
i'm going to paste it in my directory
okay
and what i'm going to do is basically
just copy the direction
if you have a mac
and
you can just uh do it this way but i
believe you have to enable this this
thing okay it's not as um
i believe it doesn't come like this and
by default the the computer so
but it's pretty easy i i just watched a
youtube tutorial i was right now i don't
quite remember how was it but it was
like some trick around here
but it was a pretty easy thing to do
okay so we have our directory the
address of our directory in my
computer once i downloaded this
and now just go ahead
and
we do something like this
the data frame
i'm just going to call it avocado okay
and avocado is going to be equal to a
pandas dot read csv ah it's not a csv
it's actually the file is like this
let me just um
be sure of that
that's a read
read pico no so yeah it's like
it's like this this is the actual thing
okay and here
we are just going to do like
air
which stands for read
we open the
quotation strings for that for to write
the a string which is going to be our
address our
direction from our directory this is the
way that we have to do it pd.readpico
this is the method then we write the the
r
for read
and the address that we
have our file
okay let's just execute this and now we
have we should have our data frame
avocado
dots heads
and see what happens yes we have our
data from here perfect
and so we see that this is the end
result which is um
let me just check
what's the data type of this mv sold
which we can do by doing data frame dot
and the
sold that's gonna tell us
oh my god
i'm just so used to call everything just
df
okay
sorry uh this is a series what what we
want is to index to get a specific
element a specific value of this column
to see
if it is actually and like
if it's like a number of what kind of
thing it is so because if we later have
to aggregate this and we want it to be
like a numeric type so i just want to
make sure yes it is a
numpy float 64. this is like a
numeric form which is which coming from
the numpy model
and
which is actually
where pandas is based pandas was built
in numpy so if you see numpy there's
absolutely no problem
okay
and what we want is the total and be
sold
so we want to aggregate all this by a
sun we want to sum all of this
and and we want to do it for the
avocados that are organic
which i'm guessing that the organic
it's within the type column but
we can find out
here avocado
dot
type
dot unique and this is going to give us
the unique values and yeah guys we see
this is uh the organic is in
is in this column okay it's existing in
this column and there's actually only
two values two unique values it's
conventional and organic okay so
we see that as i said is we will have to
filter by this organic
okay so
we'll just get records that um
in in which we have that organic is true
we have the first column that we want to
filter
okay and what's the other column in 2017
okay
oh actually this is like this data frame
it's uh not very complicated i mean they
even put us like a year here so it's so
like easy
what i'm thinking that i want to create
is kind of like this
boolean condition
which takes in
um
which filters by this
two columns you know the type and the
year
so we can create a
a boolean
boolean condition
which is going to be equal to um
it has to comply one thing
and it has to comply another thing
so one thing that it has to comply is
that
the
avocado
adds type
or actually i'm just gonna do it like
this type
and
has to be equal to
organic
and
avocado at
here
so this is just another way to
take a column okay we can do it this way
or we can simply do it this way we have
both ways to do it okay and
i just um
use it really exchangeable and
i
don't think it's too much um
and just use the the first one that
comes to my mind like naturally i don't
know
but uh
right now let's just leave it like this
so we can say this is equal to
and
the year 2017.
so
that way
you know we are creating what this is
going to be is
it's going to be like an array
okay of
truths and falses
and
and these truths and falses are going to
come from of course this condition so
it's going to go here for instance the
first row and it's going to check that
it's not compliant with this condition
and it's not compliant with this
condition
so
and it's going to return a false okay
and even if this would have been organic
even in that scenario
and
this still has to be a 2017 in order for
this to work out because this is why i'm
i'm establishing an and
um
operator so this and this has to comply
okay another way would have
been to the or but in this case it's
like any of these conditions if it
complies any of these conditions it's
going to return a true but this is not
the case right now we are using an and
operator so both conditions has to be
true has been met true so that is going
to return a true and store it in this
variable boolean
boolean is too serious name i think i'm
just going to call it um
avocado
i know
okay
all right guys so we have our
conditional here
so we have our our boolean expression
here
which we are going to pass to this data
frame to filter for the records that we
want
and so
we are going to
say data for avocado
and organic
2017
it's equal to avocado
filter
filter with this thing right here
now let's see
uh i think
the problem here is that apparently all
of these are falses
and that is because
these are not stored as um strings you
know
if we see
type of
avocado dot here
we will see
sorry
we'll see that this is a number okay so
this should be
a number as well if we want this to work
out because otherwise
m is not gonna find it 2017 in any of
these things because the the data type
is completely different so
we really have to be careful with that
guys
now so i'm gonna execute it again
i'm gonna execute this
okay so basically the problem was that
apparently we have
to
put here the parenthesis
i was missing on that thing
so it should be a tuple actually
and now it should work out
now let's see the avocado
work
2017
but
had
we can see guys we have the organic and
the 2017
so now
so now we can go ahead of course and do
the
aggregation
and be sold
and we are going to choose some of these
things
and this would be the solution for
exercise
number two
let's go ahead and try to solve now the
third question
just create a bar plot of the total
number of homeless people by region
in the homelessness data frame order the
bars in descending order bonus create a
horizontal bar chart okay so we can
create a horizontal bar chart
[Music]
so
um
yeah
we can
i guess
with this data frame we can group by
the region information then of course
we can
sum the total of number the total number
of homeless people for each region
and then we can create this this a
horizontal bar chart
okay so let's go ahead and and
let's go ahead on first i want to have
this here so i'm just gonna do this
like that i don't know if this is really
useful actually but okay yeah
okay
question three
question three
and okay so
we are going to come here
to my to my jit hub profile
and i'm going to search for the
homelessness csv
we get it from
raw
now we're just gonna take this
this link
and we're gonna do it and
we're gonna create our
homelessness
data frame is going to be equal to
pv.read
csb because it's a csv file
and we are going to just paste this
i execute it
and
now
our homelessness data from should be
working
yes we still have this
column that i really don't like but
we're just gonna leave it there okay now
it's not bothering me as much i don't
know
okay let's just put a bunch of cells
here okay and
so
what i want to do is okay maybe i can
check a little bit of information
about this data frame
we see how we have 51 entries this is 51
records 51 and
ros
and we don't have any
new or missing values
so we have all the information that we
need
i mean we don't have to be cleaning up
anything here everything looks uh
everything looks pretty good okay
so
now what i would propose to do is take
this data frame
and we're going to apply the group by
method and we're just going to group it
by
region
and then we're going to aggregate this
we're going to aggregate
region state the individuals
so these are the
homeless
and number of people
and we introduce here like
if it was like a dictionary or something
like that
i mean it's a dictionary
it's a weird dictionary okay so in the
key of the dictionary we have the the
column label
and in the value of the dictionary we're
going to have the
aggregation method in this case it's
going to be we're going to use the sum
of course it's going to sum
uh the indi all the individuals and we
are going to save this in home
homeless
and
pair
region
like that
and now if we see this execute this we
can see
how we have the number of individuals
the number of homeless
people
per region which is what we wanted
now we want to create a horizontal bar
plot for that what we're going to do is
we are going to call the plt
the plt
model
which is the submodel of
matlab lib
and we're just going to do bar
horizontal
and we're going to introduce the
rx
which is going to be this thing
but kind of like the individuals
sorry
the x
okay so the x it should be the region it
should be the region yes
so this should be and because this is an
index this is this is not a column guys
okay so i cannot say here like region
this is going to give me a mistake it's
not going to take this thing
and in order to call this
we need to to to and
type here that this is the index because
this is the index of this
data frame of only one column okay so we
have to call it like this index and now
it's going to take this
okay
and for my
following value we are going to have
these individuals and which is going to
be like
in
individuals like this empty videos okay
and let's see what happens
if i just
put here the show command
okay nice we don't have any mistake
and also one thing we can do is
we can actually um
i'm thinking that i can sort this
so the values and
oh
we are going to have our individuals
because we want to sort it by the
individuals and then establish the
ascending
sending equal true
see here i see like this
it's a little bit um
weird i will put the ascending true
because we want to we want to see like
the top
but and for the bar plot it's kind of
weird okay
and and
sometimes you have to play with this i
put it like true false whatever until we
have the outcome that we actually want
and i just remember that i had to put
the truth because at the beginning i had
i was always putting false and
i didn't like the shape of my bar plot
so now i learned the lesson and always
put like this true if we want to kind of
like see
the top measurements and
in the above part of the graph
and so here we have our bar plot guys
this would be the this is the solution
for this
for this particular question i'm just
checking that everything is okay that
looks okay
one thing i wanted to show you guys
which i think is pretty pretty pretty
cool and i use this all the time is that
we can
come to these websites and we can
actually
and
see a lot of different palettes and
different colors that we might want for
our graphs
and i just have so much fun with these
guys i really really love it
so i would just go
go here and just explore different
palettes and different colors
and
until i see one that i really like for
instance
what i'm liking right now
i really like this color
so i'm just gonna take it like when you
click on it it's already copied so you
don't have to do anything else and then
when you come here you can just specify
that the color is equal to
and now the only thing that you have to
do is type a hashtag so that it
understands that it's like a
color code
and then you will paste what you copied
in here
and now if i execute this it should
change the color to the
to the color we selected from the from
that website
and this would be the result which is i
think it's it's really really beautiful
and
i think also
it would be nice if we specify here in
the x axis
and
that these are the
individuals the number of homeless
individuals
so
what i can do is we can go plt dot y
label
sorry x label
let me just type here number
of homeless
people
and that should appear in here like this
perfect guys
and now i think we can go to the fourth
question
which is create a line plot
with two lines representing the
temperatures in toronto and wrong
make sure to properly label your plots
bonus add a legend for the two lines yes
that is what i was thinking
and
okay so just like before i'm going to do
it this way i'm gonna put here like
question
question four i'm just gonna create here
a bunch of cells
okay and so
first i'm gonna import the data set
for that i'm just going to come here
to our temperatures
csv
perfect
i'm gonna to row
it's just gonna copy this
and now it's like temperatures it's
equal to this is my the demo it's gonna
be the name of my data frame this is
gonna be go to pd.read
csv
here i'm gonna paste my dataset
my uh direction
so now if i just come here and call the
head
okay we see we have actually our data
set here okay so let's go ahead and
let's see what we can do here and
what i would propose
it's to create a
individual
data frame
for
our rom city and the toronto city so two
separated data frames
and then
and with each of these data frames we
can
then plot them
in the same graph
and then we can label them and
and
i think that's what i would do uh to
answer this question and so
let's create our first data frame
which it would be like this so
is the temperature let's call it
temperature
rom
so we can say that this new data frame
is going to be the entire data frame
and filter for the cd of rom
okay
and so i should have everything and but
only for the city
that is equal to rom so just for the
wrong city okay so and let's go ahead
and
do like this temp
data frame
where
the temp
and
and this is like right now i'm just
trying to get this city
city like this
it's equal to
rome
and by the way now i'm just
curious and how is rom
written in this column
so
i don't know if maybe
i don't know maybe it has like a
like like it's not capitalized so it's
like a
a lowercase letter so i want to check
that out so that i don't have problems
when i'm filtering and the data set
so what i can do here it's actually temp
dot
city so that we are only selecting this
column so right now
we have this this uh series or this
column here series and column is the
basically the same thing in pandas model
and we are going to uh what are we gonna
do oh yeah so we are gonna get the
unique values
and so we can see where rom stands this
is in alphabetical order so it's very
easy to spot
what we're looking for and we had it
like this is wrong so
this should be okay because it's like
it's the same and
it's the same letters and it's the same
capitalization and everything
so
we can go ahead now and
yeah
this should create our data set here
now
if we actually go ahead and maybe look
at some
some rows of our new data set we are
going to see that we only have the rom
city
so
so that's great so we have the wrong
part covered
now let's do exactly the same thing for
toronto
and we're gonna call this temp
turon to uh here let's see
okay
let's go with this
okay
this is being created and
it's working fine also we can see
that toronto
it's here is exactly the same as as here
so there's no problem with that as well
and now we can we can go ahead and start
plotting our data frames i mean
we're only going to be plotting the
average temperature i guess because we
have to make the plot of the temperature
representing the temperatures into
return around
yeah so we're going to plot the average
temperature for each city
and for each of these both cities
along with the
with the dates okay and now i'm curious
as well and about what is the data type
of uh
the values
of this date column if these are
actually like
like time stamps or date time and
type of data
or if these are like strings because i
think that's going to make a difference
when we do the plotting
so let's go ahead and
just
see for instance if we grab this one or
yeah let's just grab this one i guess
this one should work fine
and we go to take the date
and we say that
we want just to grab um a random element
and let's just say that we want it in
this index and see what happens
okay
so we see this is a string
yeah guys
and
i really would like to have this in time
time stamp i think
would be better
thing to do
so i'm gonna go ahead and just convert
this from the string to date time
to
date time data type
and this should be fairly easy because
i think the format of this string is
already
pretty straightforward and so pandas can
detect it very easily and can
automatically convert it to a daytime
and so
what we can do it's
um take for instance our
temperature toronto
where
we have this date
and we can set this
equal to these the dates
sorry
we should start by saying
pd.2 datetime
and now we can put our date here and
this should convert it
so
yeah guys this happens to me a lot it
suggests me to use the lock
but this still should work so
i i think there's like
there should be shouldn't be any problem
and
with this the execution of this sale
and now let's verify that this is
actually a daytime data type and
by doing
just taking the
temperature date
why index it maybe at one of these
values
we can see yeah effectively it's a time
stamp now so i think this is gonna be
way better to when we are
plotting our
our columns
and
now let's go ahead and do the same for
the rom for the rom data set
so i'm just going to
copy this
i'm gonna say that
here i want rom
and is the same
same column label because they are both
coming from the same
data frame so
that's okay
and this should be wrong
now we execute this
uh-huh the same thing here
and now let's say that i want
just to check the data type but of
course now we should grab one of these
index and by the way we can easily get
rid of these weird index numbers just by
saying
and reset index just by applying that
method
and that easily should take care of this
and it will be reset to the 0 1 2 3 4.
but right now we don't care about
changing the index because we just care
about this column and we
sorry we just care about
this column
and we just care about this column and
the same for this data set because we
are only going to use
those things for our plotting which is
what
is asked
okay so but let's say we have this index
just because i just want to check the
type
and yeah effectively it's a time stamp
okay so now
both of our
date columns
in both
data frames
are timestamp
data type or timestamp or datetime it's
exactly the same in pandas
datetime and timestamp is exactly the
same there's absolutely no difference
so yeah i believe a timestamp is how
pandas
call this kind of like date
handles this date
data
and then for for for python
and for the general python i believe
it's daytime or maybe maybe it's the
opposite let me just check it here
maybe it's the opposite time
stamp
versus oh look
i already i think i already searched for
this i believe a few
a few weeks ago
time time is the pandas together of
pandas of python's data so for python
it would be daytime and for pandas it
would be times time so i think that's
how how i said it i'm not sure but
anyways this is the correct
this is the correct statement okay so
and that's why it's a equivalent because
pandas just calls timestamp what is a
daytime for python so they're really
exchangeable
and
at least when we are working in pandas
and so that's why we have here that is a
timestamp because that's how pandas call
it
okay so that's that's fine
now we can go ahead and start plotting
let's do our plots here
and we can do
plt dot
plot
and we start let's start with rom let's
plot rom so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take this data frame
okay
and let's take
the oh sorry let's take
this
column here
okay so this is what what is going to be
in the x axis
so
before this
we should have
our
we should have
our
date
so in the x-axis we have our date
and the y-axis we would have our average
temperature and so we will see the
how is the evolution of the temperature
um
along with the with the dates with the
time
so this is going to be one plot actually
i think i can just
go ahead now and show it i believe
so it looks something like this which
now i'm remembering how the solution was
and it was
something like when i saw it at the
beginning i thought like there was i
don't know something wrong because it's
like so so weird at least uh the first
time i saw it like
the first instant
then like i take the solution and
everything and yeah it's it's something
like this
and i mean if you really see it and
carefully it kind of makes sense you
know some days are
it just changes a lot right because
it's i guess the seasonality
really makes
a difference for that uh how's the
temperature going
and now we can go ahead and do the same
thing for our
[Applause]
for
toronto
to run to date
and we have to run here as well
as you show it yeah it's showing both
plots
and
this is why we need to label them
and guys because we we here if you if
you only see the graph you cannot know
what is wrong what is toronto you just
see a bunch of lines here so
we definitely need to label this and we
are going to do it this way
later i mean i think it's the only way
you can do it
i mean
the only way i know how to do it and the
most common one so
let's just put the label here let's say
wrong
[Music]
and here let's say that this is
toronto
okay
and one other another thing that we need
is plt.legend
because this plt.legend
and that's what's going to
activate what that that's what's going
to like actually and create a little box
in which we are going to have our
label texts
so if we go ahead and do this we are
going to have it like this here
and there's also a really cool feature
um
in the in the legend method of plt which
is that we can actually go ahead and
and try to locate the
this box in the best position
in this graph so we can do it like best
i think it was something i always
confused let's see if this time i get it
right
and
best
no no it was
location equal best
okay apparently this is the best
spot that we have so okay let's just
leave it like that
and
and then i guess another thing it would
be really cool to put here is the plt
dot
y label so we can
actually um
and the average temperature
so yeah this should work out and this is
pretty clear that these are dates so i
don't think we should put anything here
um
i think another thing we can do for the
legend is that we can go ahead and
and change the transparency so that
maybe we can see a little bit better
these lines
and
we can do that i believe with the alpha
alpha i believe it is
or is not
okay
still running i think there's a clear
problem here of uh unexpected keyboard
okay so this doesn't exist so sometimes
what i do i mean or i would say a lot of
times what i usually do is
i come here to
[Music]
to the to whatever method i want to
analyze
and
a really cool feature here in jupyter
notebook is that you can use the
shift tab
and it's [ __ ]
okay shift tab and you can see a
bit of documentation about this
that specific method that you have
selected
and i'm not sure if this is a particular
way to do it in in a mac but anyways you
can figure out in these
options here so it shouldn't be any
problem
and
so let's see what's the problem here
because i believe there was an alpha
alpha parameter to to set
a specific transparency
[Music]
this is what i was saying about the
location
best location
yeah we can also do all of these ones
if we if we want
um
another one that i'm searching for which
is of
let's see what it is let's see what it
is
[ __ ] there's a lot of things here
transparency or maybe if we just started
here
transparency
legend
natalie
all right this looks very nice
it affects both the background and the
edge
how can i apply transparency only
to the background and not to the edge i
have tried edge color phase color
we can we can apply it to to both of
them
there's no problem
so i'm just gonna grab this
and
type it here maybe
yeah
nice it's definitely yeah it's
definitely way more transparent so i
think
it can be really um nice it's it's a
very clear this
um the lines that are behind the box
so
so that's that's great
and
but what if i set it to like 0.2 let's
see what happens maybe it's like it's
too clear
that's yeah that's that's like too clear
i don't think
it really looks too great
i think i like it like this i would just
leave like like this
and and something else that we can do
here it we can
make it bigger
this image you can make it bigger too so
so that's like more clear
and i believe we can do that like the
same
plt dot
fix size i believe it was fixed size
now let's see some documentation
i'm not sure it was fixed size
oh let me just
search here
plt
size
something like that
how do i change this other figures
drawing module yeah stack overflow is a
really good one i always
normally go there to check everything
that i need
and i can't uh figure out like the
syntax for myself kind of like i have an
idea of what i want
but i really forget the syntax of
a lot of the commands so i spend a lot
of time in this kind of website and
especially stack overflow which is one i
really really like and and it has just a
lot of
people behind like we see for instance
this comment it's been voted like a
thousand times so
and there's just a lot of people here
and it's a very very helpful community
so how do i change the size of your
charm up for the figure tells you from
uplift
import figure figure
create an inch by inch image
figure fixed size okay
i think that's going to work i think
this
dpi is kind of like the
density per inch which is just to
establish like the quality of the thing
and because i'm not going to export
this image as a png or another like
extension
i'm not really interested in that
argument so i'm just gonna i'm not gonna
use it
just
forget about this one
oh damn it
let's see
[ __ ] losing my mind here
let me just
maybe
do it here all right this worked
so
we just had to
to put it at the beginning
okay i'm thinking that this is because
first
um
kind of like the figure has to be like
created right like
the which is kind of like a container of
everything right and then you start
adding the data
adding the text adding the whatever it's
within this
axis canvas
and so
yeah like it's it's it can be kind of
like a
very intuitive right because if we first
put the data
and then
we define the size of our figure
it's like the data already
has like a size i don't know so probably
it's not going to change if we put it
after but if we put it at the beginning
we're already establishing what is the
size of the whole thing and then the
data the the data points are
in a certain position across the entire
figure
and so
yeah
you know guys this is
really cool when you really like try by
by yourself always
because it's only when you make
the mistake
that you will actually learn it because
i don't know like i heard this uh
podcast
and from
a neuroscientist
his name is andrew huberman and he was
talking about how to learn faster and
the best way to to learn and to optimize
learning
is to
is to make mistakes along the way the
more mistakes you make actually the more
you're going to learn and this is
because
when you make a mistake
it's kind of like
your
your neuro your neuro and
neurochemicals everything that is in
your
neurological system
everything kind of like changes like its
configuration changes
right and it has to like re-adapt
and when that happens
when that happens there's a
open
it's like an openness for your
brain plasticity
so your
brain plasticity goes up significantly
and
the higher the neuroplasticity
and the higher you can the higher is the
rate the rate of observing information
and
and the more retention along time so
if you really want to learn something
you have to
try it and you have to make the mistakes
and and even we
be willing to make the mistakes you know
and
and and this is also very like i don't
know like
hopeful
because you you make a mistake and
you're normally like frustrated about it
right you're frustrated because
and you think you know
you are
you are like wrong you're not doing it
correctly or whatever and so you get
frustrated and then you want to
give up on
what you're doing
but if you can just remember that
when you are doing the mistake
it's actually for the better for your
better development
for for you to actually learn fast some
to learn something faster and
that can really like change your i don't
know your psychology about that right
and actually motivate you to to keep
going you know
and be like also
a physical
physical a psychological and support
there right so you can keep going
so yeah i always try to remember that
and but yeah guys i mean
this uh this was everything i had for
today
and
as i was saying i i took this and
all these questions
from
data camp
so these questions were here like in
data camp
and i just like uh did them first i
compared with their solutions
and i checked that everything was
correct and then
you know
and i felt you know kind of like
confident i know that i could teach this
now i also want to say
that i'm not
data science we with an official
background in data science or anything
like that
and
i actually just learning data science on
my own
and this channel is basically kind of
like a recording of this journey as i
try to become a data science
and
basically all the or most of the videos
what's what's gonna be is that i'm gonna
be making a project and i'm gonna record
myself doing the project
and i'll just upload it
as a video in this channel
and then i will always provide all the
tools and resources that you will need
and to follow along the project so you
can also try the project by yourself
and then if you get stuck
or you also want to watch an alternative
way to solve the the questions you can
watch how i do it
and we compare you can compare like the
ways on how to proceed and i think
that's also a really useful thing
my official background is actually i
studied a chemical engineering and
business management so it is not
very related to data science maybe a
little bit of statistics and programming
i did in in my bachelor's degree
but nothing too specific about
programming or
or machine learning or
i think when i was in college i i didn't
even know what machine learning was too
much
and one big component for why i started
this channel is that i firmly believe
that
to master something and you
have to teach it
okay to really learn something very well
it's very important that that you teach
it and this is something
that richard feynman which is uh one of
the greatest physicists of all time
and he he always say this that and if
you if you really want to understand
something
you have to also teach it so that's why
you know i i got um enthusiastic about
um you know solving these projects which
i was going to solve it anyways
and i thought maybe because i don't have
anyone to teach right and uh i wasn't
sure if i like could even teach you know
because i'm like not a data science
expert i i'm just gonna record videos
about me doing these projects
with solutions that i'm certain that are
correct that i'm actually getting to the
right answers of these projects
and just sharing it with people and see
what happens and i think this really can
be useful uh to people because you know
projects
is a way in which you actually
do something right and it's it's really
by doing that you can learn uh learn
something you know so
i think this can be i i think i hope
this can be useful to other people and
if you are someone who is in a similar
journey ask me of becoming a data
scientist
or
just want to improve your data skills
maybe these videos will be useful
to you hopefully
you